[Musique]
la belgique a vécu sa quatrième semaine
de grève marquée quant à oddo ken près
d'anvers de défilés et de manifestations
contre la loi unique adoptée par la
chambre celle ci conserve des ennemis
déterminés
parmi eux les élus socialistes wallons
hauteur de l'adresse au roi qui met en
cause les institutions unitaire de la
belgique parmi eux surtout andré renard
le leader syndicaliste wallon qui prêche
toujours la continuation de la grève
dans les centres où la troupe a relayé
la police pour la protection des usines
un allègement c'est pourtant manifesté
si les provinces de liège et du hainaut
demeure installé dans la grève les
fédérations anversoise et gantoise ont
ordonné la reprise du travail et à liège
même pour la première fois depuis trois
semaines les trams ont recommencé à
circuler
[Musique]
à paris en présence du général de gaulle
la place dauphine a changé de nom elle
portera désormais celui du maréchal de
france de lattre de tassigny
il n'est que juste dira le président de
la république que paris graves sur ses
murs le nom du maréchal de lattre
c'est à dire celui d'un soldat d'un chef
d'un homme qui fut grande quand c'était
difficile
701 scellage aujourd'hui de la
cathédrale de chartres qui ne la connaît
en france ou ailleurs son histoire elle
se raconte tout au long des enluminures
du temps et gravures des siècles
suivants dans ses tableaux terme tout un
monde se dévoile le monde du miracle de
chartres le monde des 10000
rassemblèrent de la pierre de dieu comme
les nomme à peggy dont le nom de ce
peuple c'est près de chartres car en ce
temps là pour rebâtir l'église détruite
par un incendie
un peuple entier se mit à l'ouvragé
trente années durant le ciel de la
beauce pu voir monter à 6 par assises
les colonnes et les statuts qui
accompagne chaque étage le plus pauvre
apporta sa pierre et des milliers de
tailleur de maçon de charpentier et
d'imagiers dessinèrent sous les ordres
d'un architecte dassieu est génial dans
le nom est resté inconnu
l'énorme vaisseau qui devait apparaître
dans sa blancheur de nouveautés à la fin
de l'an mille deux cent soixante
[Musique]
on avait vu les fidèles s'atteler au
chariot les riches comme les pauvres
servir de compagnon aux hommes de métier
on avait vu dans cet élan général qui
fut peut-être l'un des grands instants
nationaux les flèches monte plus haut
que tous les édifices existants pour
être ce symbole touchant et insensé de
ce que peut faire la fois d'un peuple
il faut revenir à peggy tour de david
voici votre tour beauceronne c'est les
piles plus dure qui soit jamais monté
vers un ciel de clémence et de sérénité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'un chat puisse être le client du
festival mondial des oiseaux rien à cela
que deux parfaitement logique
les chats aiment les oiseaux et si nous
nous suivons le boeuf le chat lui suit
son idée s'il est sensible aux champs
des canaries il préfère est lié amitié
avec quelqu'un de plus consistant et
dans cette exposition on a 1000 poids
cas là où c'est tout quand de toutes
sortes les virus très but certes idées
pour les 1m fasti des terreaux gloss
l'accord inquiets c'est une idée pour
les autres c'est simple brute pour année
d'afrique australe joli mais farouche
d'étranglement satire qui nonobstant
anneaux à faire peur tiennent plutôt de
la pintade et de la perdrix
sympathique mais trop vert sans doute un
tokyo des flamands mais ces messieurs à
gros becs habite vraiment trop on finira
chez les perroquets mais qu'il est mal
commode de s'inviter chez d'aussi fichu
caractère 7 à des occupations disons
plus élevé qu'on a convié octobre hector
est un charmant rappelant que les
spécialistes français destinées aux
voyages dans l'espace
mais on n'est pas un rat de l'espace
comme ça pour l'accomplissement de sa
haute mission hector a été dotée d'une
combinaison spéciale qui se fixe par des
ressorts abati métalliques dans cet
appareil
hector s'est vu conviés aux délices de
l'entraînement spatiale et en
particulier à ceux de la centrifugeuse
d'en donner un avant-goût du vol sans
pesanteur
[Musique]
avec hector six autres rats s'entraîne
au centre d'études et de recherches de
la médecine astronautique et comme lui
il pourra le jour j avoir l'honneur de
prendre place dans l'habitacle de la
fusée véronique et de faire depuis la
base d'un aggir près de colomb béchar le
bord de 200 km dans l'espace
[Musique]
aux etats unis ce sont des chimpanzés
qui se préparent au grand voyage par une
visite médicale très serré comme on voit
mais si ceux qui auront l'honneur
d'ouvrir à l'homme la voix du cosmos
doivent avoir bon pied bon oeil
on leur demande aussi autre chose que
d'être des passagers inerte aussi
cultive-t-on leur intellect ou du moins
leurs réflexes dans leur habitacle
ils devront en effet savoir obtenir eux
mêmes leur nourriture donc actionné la
bonne manette
[Musique]
et dans un monde sans pesanteur ils
devront savoir aspirer leur boisson
favorite
on peut tout de même pas espérer que de
bons moments dans l'espace et les futurs
astronautes américains ont dû aussi
s'habituer au terrible accélération du
lancement
à quand le grand départ
[Musique]
on n'arrête pas le progrès et le progrès
donne raison aux automobilistes pressés
contre la voiture à bras qui se traîne
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi désormais nous ne verrons
sans doute plus le petit déménageurs on
envoyait encore quelques-uns transporté
ses pénates d'un bout à l'autre de paris
le moteur vient de marquer un nouveau
point un décret va étendre à toute la
capitale l'interdiction aux voitures à
bras de circuler
on aurait pu évidemment envisager
d'autres solutions moins radicales
rendre obligatoire le port des patins à
roulettes par exemple ce qui eût permis
d'aller plus vite ou bien encore obligé
les usagers des voitures abraham unir
leurs véhicules d'un quelconque système
de démultiplication tel celui de
l'inventeur bien connu claude b cogner
qui est permis lui aussi d'accélérer le
mouvement
et ces solutions semble-t-il ont dû être
écartés à cause des excès de vitesse due
à de possibles pertes du contrôle
[Musique]
rist temps on a choisi l'interdiction
excellent début des skieurs français
dans les grandes compétitions
internationales de sports d'hiver
ce sont les skieuses qui ont ouvert le
bal des restes d'une grande
triomphatrice du slalom spécial de
grindelwald se classe quatrième de la
descente un peu essoufflée mais
souriante tout de même perdu à wengen
succès beaucoup plus éclatant encore des
skieurs français charles bozon sans
prendre de risques dans un style très
cool et termine 3e du slalom du
lauberhorn
c'est pas mal du tout pour un début de
saison voici 10 périllat également dans
le slalom
perrillat se contente de glisser en
souplesse ce n'est pas un spécialiste
ce qu'il préfère par dessus tout c'est
la vitesse pour lui une seule épreuve
importante la descente il se colle
d'impôt classement au slalom
le vainqueur du slalom c'est
l'autrichien spiegler qui s'efforce de
marcher sur les traces de toni sailer il
a beaucoup moins d'aisance pendant la
descente du lauberhorn
c'est le triomphe de guy périllat lancé
comme un bolide sur des rails périllat
plonge vers l'arrivée beaucoup d'audace
de la virtuosité de l'élégance dans le
geste voilà ce qu'il faut pour gagner
une grande épreuve internationale et
pourrait être considéré comme le
meilleur skieur de tous les temps
toni sailer a trouvé son successeur sans
aucun doute
[Musique]